I was trying to find a legend we haven't
talked about yet and I decided Babe Ruth
but they told me I couldn't do it
because his chess game was a little iffy
so we're going to Samuel Reshevsky now
unfortunately in real life Samuel
Reshevsky was a suspicious character
okay some would say a cheater some would
like me anyway reshef ski wasn't a nice
person but he's a great chess player
so if we can call Fischer a legend then
reshef skis twice the legend okay so I
mean we reckon we're I could take the
character of the person into account by
their chess game now reshef ski was a
child prodigy giving simultaneous
exhibitions at a very young age and
basically his career spanned almost 50
years playing top level chess basically
I would say he was the only American
player who could you know challenge
Fischer and you know play with him
without being a huge huge huge underdog
let's slide underdog now one other thing
I liked about Reshevsky is he lived in
Detroit for a while which is where I'm
from
although it was four years before I was
born but that shouldn't stop you know me
from liking that fact and he actually
went to school in Michigan college and a
lot of the tournaments that he played in
in the 30s and 40s were in Detroit and I
actually have heard of some of these
players because recently I was inducted
into the Michigan chess Hall of Fame and
some of these players were inducted into
the Hall of Fame before I was born
so I recognize some of these names and
of course my dad was the chess master so
he told me about all these guys okay so
the first game on his show reshef ski
was black against Marvin Palmer Marvin
Marvin
was one of the best chess players in
Michigan in the 30s and 40s
now pushing arrow didn't help okay
Andrew chefs he's black I'll try to have
the player with black on the lower side
now one of the things I like about
Reshevsky is normally when you look at
games from 1900 to 1940 you basically
see slobs and Queen's Gambit declines
and Cambridge Springs when you see D
four openings the Kings Indian wasn't
very popular but reshef ste liked to
play his own openings play the way he
wanted and play very sharp and since he
was living in Michigan and his opponents
weren't world-class he had to win and
when you have to win you don't want to
play openings that are totally equal or
our draw is the most likely result and
unfortunately a lot of the super GM's
today will do just such a thing with
black they'll try to draw with black and
then try to win with white well if
you're paired down a lot and you're
playing people who are two three or four
hundred points low rated than you you
got to win with black and actually most
people don't know this because you know
we live in America but in America most
of the tournaments are open tournaments
where if you win the tournament you get
a lot of money if you don't win the
tournament then you don't so players of
America like Christensen and Shabanov
and like any many others with that kind
of style they play to win with white and
black and a lot of the strong European
grandmasters if they can win with why to
draw with black and come in the top ten
of the top 15 that's reasonable and the
rating goes up but in the US you have to
win win win win win and we see a lot of
sharp openings
okay so reshef skis playing the Kings
Indian not the most popular opening in
1933 and okay you got to give the
players a break because opening theory
in 1933
I think his internet was down for about
60 years so he couldn't really you know
figure out the right opening strategy
okay now each three is actually very
popular right now Bishop e2 was the most
popular move maybe age three is tied for
first now everybody's playing h3 now
okay now we're chefs keep late-night FG
seven this is a bit of a strange move
but he spends the opening attacking the
dark squares he doesn't play for a five
he plays for c5 and he tries to attack
d4 and he five which is a very
reasonable idea and obviously the
players are on their own now and reshef
ski keeps attacking the center white
advances and they have a very strange
game where well I sort of like white a
little bit white has more space but
black has a nice Bishop on g7 knight on
e5 and it looks sort of like a benoni
okay whoops went too far digit of h6 I
don't like fact I tell my students this
a lot before you do anything you should
be ready to do it so why didn't castle
why didn't move his bishop off of f1 you
can't really blame them the bishops on
f1 and why it's already attacking with
the move Bishop h6 okay now a chef's key
point a very strange move f6 and I think
it has a couple of ideas one is to trap
the bishop forcing the trade and the
other one gives us 90 to retreat square
which also forces the bishops either
trade or move away
although f6 isn't a move that I would
have thought of but okay so Bishop e2
Bishop to d7 h4 usually something has
gone wrong well you play h3 than h4 now
as I was playing this game over earlier
today I was thinking hmmm I wonder what
the computer things computer is always
like white in the King's Indian but in
fact even though blacks playing sword is
strange and I think White's playing
strange
computer extra likes black queen to see
a another strange move but trying to
take control of this diagonal that well
white sort of gave up you played h3 to
control the g4 square now black can play
Bishop g4 or more likely Knight to g4
this checkmating attack that white has I
mean he plays h5 black plays g5 so
there's no real attack here and black
has his pieces out and whites King is
still in the center so I don't like
white strategy of Bishop h6 and then h4
ok f3 defending the g4 square a6 playing
on the Queen side which we do with the
Benoni
Black's going to play b5 the thing is if
white castles Queen side blacks ready to
play b5 & if white castles King side why
did he play h4 so White's play is very
strange
g4 okay so now he's intentions are clear
b5 the problem is although White's
trying to attack on the Kings side his
King is in safe on a1 and black already
has a threat blacks already attacking
the c4 pawn now more importantly in my
opinion maybe not yours this is a very
complicated position that is very
unlikely to lead to a draw and that's
what you're going for when you're
playing a lower rated player you want a
position where it's likely your opponent
will make mistakes and if your opponent
plays better than you then they play
better than you you don't want a game
where the computer says equal equal
equal equal draw you want to where the
computer is confused and that's what
reshef ski and Marvin were thinking what
does the computer think right
in 1933 they're like what's the computer
evaluation okay
so King f2 very suspicious but white
didn't have a good place for his King go
to the Queen side black sari opening
that up Kings side I already pushed all
of his pawns
so King F to the ID I think is to just
get the rook over here and play for an
attack which doesn't exist okay Black's
a pawn up takes on c4 they trade bishops
rigged into g1 and black plays h6 which
effectively closes the Kings side
there's no way that white can crash
through and if plaque is able to he
could even play g5 and then the bishop
is terrible on e - maybe our Knights
going to swing in f4 9 2 d1 rip to b8
and basically blacks blacks upon ahead
for nothing and black has another threat
Queen takes B - I don't think white
wants to play Knight to d1 I don't think
Y wants to play rook to be one that sort
of ends his attack so he goes all-in f4
ok and then you know sometimes when you
go all-in the guy calls you then you
lose all your chips Green takes b2
sacrificing a piece when I first saw
this I thought that guy's crazy
okay and then the computer said that
guy's a genius
man the computers like whites going to
lose all of his pawns Black's going to
have a million pawns for a piece and an
attack white says thank you for the
piece and black tanks would check now
the tables have turned black has the
attack black has all the pawns and
whites pawns are all weak a 2 is hanging
efore is going to be hanging soon and
got a passed pawn over here just in case
also white is in check white has to play
King you won because yes so to save his
Bishop rook to f4 there's no defense to
the e4 pawn Knight takes e4 rook takes a
2 and all of whites pawns are weak his
King is exposed and his rooks are
terrible
if only white could get his rook to the
B file then maybe he gets some counter
play wishful thinking 93
rookie for now the computer just says
blacks winning blacks attack is too
strong Black has a lot of pass pawns and
whites King is exposed and he wasn't
able to save a piece here actually he
defended his Knight
Rep Shaq well you can't move your King
because of rook takes rook maybe white
should Castle that's not illegal is it
it's a little illegal how many reasons
is it illegal for only two or three okay
so he played Bishop d1 now all of his
pieces are pinned he went for the
world's record
it was 1933 they have a big record then
Bishop to a four man this is harsh okay
and as I've said many times in my videos
but you've all forgotten at home
my favorite line The Sopranos there's
good and there's not good that's not
good okay White's position blacks
threatening rook takes Bishop check
Bishop takes Bishop rook takes III every
capture wins very suspicious he played
King e2 defending his Bishop with his
rook by discovery record check Oh
now King f3 would be good if it wasn't
from Eaton 1 but you hate when that
happens
if you were at my class that just
finished the beginners class we talked
about checkmate if King to have three
rooks f4 is me so instead he played King
the e1 we take the bishop black is of so
many pawns I can't count that high but
it's a lot and here white resigned if
white plays Knight takes that's illegal
and therefore not good and if King takes
we got a little skewer action going here
then we take the rook okay so a very
good game for a chef's key his King was
never really in danger
King was pretty safe and eventually he
sacrificed a piece and he won on both
sides of the board I could say all three
sides of the board would I know on the
Queen side the King side
the center and he had a lot of extra
pawns and all his pieces were attacking
pretty good game reshef ski was lucky a
lot every game he was lucky ok now this
is a funny game because it was played in
1934 the last kid has played in 1933 and
the reason I like this game is reshef
ski played somebody I've played before
you didn't know how old I was this is
against Arthur dake your favorite player
Malvinas like that's my favorite player
now I played Arthur dick at the 1987 US
Open where was it
anybody was anybody there now we're
there Julianne terrible it was in
Portland Oregon and I had six wins and
six draws how many rounds was it
round-robin wait it was a US Open by the
way a lot of people call the US
Championship the US Open come on
okay so the US Open had several hundred
people as it always does it was won by
level Bert which is funny I talked about
him today with one of my students and I
played Arthur Jake and there are two
funny things about Arthur Jake well he
was old that wasn't one of the funny
things but there was a like a banquet in
his honor like a USCF banquet and he
gave a speech and his speech he said I'm
glad to be here at the 1977 US Open
nobody corrected him now my favorite
thing about the tournament was we drew
we agreed to a draw like I move 20 in
some boring position and he looked at me
and he said I've played Alekhine kappa
blanka Botvinnik and i thought there was
some great wisdom coming and like and
you suck oh yeah he said he said that he
left he just wanted me to know like i
already knew that but he told me all the
great players he played he walked away
so ya later he came back with a
microphone and dropped it
then yeah dake was old-school alright so
also since we're talking about Jake I
don't know what you guys brought it up
Arnold Denker from the same kind of you
know playing in the 30s and 40s I played
in the first denker high school turn of
the champions and well they've had it
since 1985 since I played in 1985 and
who was there Arnold Denker so I've run
the gamut of Denker to Jake I think it's
a movie
okay so reshef skis playing de
Khrushchev skis white and they got again
it's the 1930 so every game is a Queen's
Gambit it's nothing you can do about it
okay Orthodox not a good choice against
for chef ski anybody get that no nothing
okay c5 this is the old cap a blanket
variation Queen c2 nowadays a more
common move is the good players in the
back anybody you it's White's move
that's why I said Queen c2 the kappa
blanka incorrect rook c1 is the most
common move as can be seen in the
hundreds and hundreds of games between
Karpov and Gaspar of and their friends
okay Queen c2 which I usually play c5
down these kind of positions black often
gets an isolated pawn now when I teach
chess to beginners if you can believe it
there are people who are more beginner
than you right Kyle
yeah Kyle's I get 200 points this month
I know a lot of beginners like to put
the knight on c6 and then do nothing the
rest of the game okay so then then I
beat them better players will want their
C pawn to move either c6 or c5 if you're
going to go to c5 might as well go in
one move so we're tagging the center
we're going to treat a lot and equalize
although often Black has a weak isolated
part okay then these kind of things
happen okay and instead of letting white
take on c5 at some point or black taking
and white taking them with a knight and
play c4
and now black has another issue this
pawn could become weak and there's no
pressure on the center so we can play e4
and 95 much more easily rookie a castle
okay now that why it's canceled unlike
other games we look at where guys start
doing stuff before they develop now why
it's ready to go white has all of his
pieces out White's castled why does a
nice Center Black has the usual problems
in the Queen's Gambit Bishop on C a
terrible can't go anywhere whereas my
common when you need them he put a black
pawn on e6 and really get mad now when
the bishops on c8
that means the rook on a8 can't get out
and these are the typical problems in
these kinds of openings Knights FA and
now he's going to trade his bishop and
all as well unfortunately Knight f8
which defends h7 trade the bishops the
knight has great squares e6 and g6
unfortunately that night was controlling
the e5 square but now white is sort of
free to come and play in the center
white traded the bishop took with the
rook Bishop takes Knight very simple and
the simplest of moves Queen f5
threatening the d5 pawn many ways to
defend it like Ricky five rook c5 great
ways to defend upon well not the best
okay and so with just very simple
captures the d5 pawn is indefensible as
is blacks opening play okay so now he's
going to lose upon these things happen
times you lose upon and they keep
playing and White has a nice Center
because you took the d5 pawn well White
has two pawns of the senator black has
zero notice white played a for stopping
counter play black could try to play b5
but there's no counterplay can't play b5
so white advances in the center whites
the best hurray for ye look at him go in
the center he knows what he's doing
okay now black didn't like the place he
had moved that he lived so he moved
where did he move crazy town yeah
so here blacks like wait a minute I
might lose another pawn and this pawn
might come crush me I better make the
game complicated okay so he sacrificed a
piece can you close the door slightly so
we can yeah music and and they got like
Fox News on there yeah I won't hear that
okay so 9 takes d4 white is like thank
you very much Knight takes e4 what
happens on Knight takes Knight
nobody knows then we could play Bishop
takes threatening rook takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight Queen takes h2
Bishop takes age to winning the Queen
and reshef skis like that's too
complicated let's just play Knight takes
e4 defending our pawn on d4 on e5 they
traded White's tulip on up black slide
in and got a pawn this is terrible
rookie 4 and black wins is pawn back now
that move is very suspicious
so sometimes at the top level the top
players will blunder and you people at
home on the internet with your 7 laptops
running and your 7 different engines are
like that moves terrible all my engine
say so well the problem is if your minus
1 or minus 2 and you know you're going
to lose you might make a minus 7 move
hoping the opponent doesn't find the
intricate way to be +7 and beat you and
black knows if the game continues
normally he's down upon his bishop has
no scope the knight has d 6b sevens weak
he's like I'm going to lose for sure but
after this
get my pawn back Hey okay so white
played h4 and blacks like wait a minute
now I'm losing a piece darn okay because
the Queen on g5 is defending the bishop
on e5 so we remove the defender if you
were here for my last lecture and you
weren't at home because we didn't tape
it and most of you other were removing
the defender that's a key element to
winning a chess he played Queen f6 white
said thank you for the free piece and
then he got a pawn for that's pretty
good okay so Queen takes h4 very
insulting much better was resigns much
better okay now most of you
unfortunately who never listened to me
when I say most of you me all of you I
always say don't trade don't trade never
trade don't trade most of you would
trade here because you're like I'm up at
night okay reshef ski slightly better
than you even now
okay he's like wait a minute I just
removed the defender of the night let's
remove the defender of the rook g3 that
when the Queen moves away we could take
the rook for nothing and dire straits
wasn't even out yet Oh in 1934 Ken
you're the expert on that
no no dire straits in 1934 although
black is in dire straits
yeah all right so I hope mark knopfler
doesn't sue me all right
and then black did the usual what's the
usual can you've done it many times in
your career resigned very good yeah so
that was a terrible finish at the end
black was so sick of being a pawn down
and being passive that he gave all his
pieces away then the game would ended it
to play anymore sorrow not great defense
well can they be Phi was 1977 I know
okay so for those of you who showed up
late this is a a and for you at home to
you like you pushed your curse you don't
know what this lecture is about
this is a lecture on Samuel Reshevsky
it's the legends and I have to flip the
bore which is impossible okay there we
go now this is a game he played against
everybody's favorite player the Estonian
Grandmaster Paul Kerr as one of the few
grandmasters if not the only one who's
on the money when you're on the money
and then you're on the money right if
you go to Estonia then you get I think
it's a five crown I think so then Paul
Kerr is on the money that's how he rolls
some grandmasters are on stamps but Paul
Kerr is on the cash
okay so Cara's was considered by many
the greatest players ever to be world
champion some people think the Soviet
authorities told him don't be botherin
it we want Bob might be the war champion
not you some people don't think that I
wasn't alive then only Ken West can tell
us what your opinion is chess historian
you told they told carrots don't be
botherin ik we need Bhavana alright
maybe again I talked to Bronstein once
on a train that was a long train ride
anyway he complained more on that train
ride than I've done the rest of my life
since but he didn't say they made him
lose or draw to bother Nick but he said
that was unfair and you know whatever
okay so reshef ski has the black pieces
and it's a Queens gambit accepted I
can't believe it
in the 1930s who would have thunk it
okay well there was a Queen's Gambit
that's very important whoa
that was the craziest thing that ever
happened I mean I don't let a very
strange life that's the craziest thing
all right let's go back it happens all
day today so I push a button and the
computer explodes by the way if you push
buttons in your computer explodes
who knows what fixes that if you don't
know at home I'm going to tell you
anybody know a whole new computer fixes
it right up and that's what you need
okay so this is act again okay so wait
what happened so I made one of those
moves by accident which is the correct
move
the first one is this one you guarantee
it this one hey you were right when
you're right you're right okay and this
you could see this today this is normal
chest veeery now remember the last game
which was a couple minutes ago so I
don't blame you for forgetting I was
complaining the bishop on C it was
terrible
well we're chefs key must have heard me
course no you Marazzi would agree that
we got to get that Bishop strong my
favorite game and this ilke is the last
game of the match between your two
favorite players in fact I was in the
board room today they were next to each
other on the wall Topalov and an on
world championship match and anon had
the bishop on b7b top love became world
champion all of India was happy
Bulgaria's like in all right Knight bt7
not again what am I doing wrong okay
Bishop III all right there we go
I blame society ok Knight c3x close that
writer that's right it's kind of the ex
claim because I didn't do it how could
it not be right oh he played a four but
Knight c3 was better
ah that's why you're the chess teacher
have you beat any grandmasters lately
I'm how many gives you be grandmasters
yesterday - that's twice as many as
usual or at some number I can't
understand
okay so 93 developing a piece but white
followed my rule always play a four
carries knew what to do okay now there's
all these variations okay that's no good
that's no good you play b4 okay now if
you want to Queen your B pawn or if your
maka a of b4 although usually plays it
with white okay so b4 is good I predict
that b-pawn will be very strong because
I saw the game and you didn't so night
BD - Queen c7 everybody's happy and
somehow
Black has all of his minor pieces out
before white although why did castle and
black didn't so I'll give them a break
95 very aggressive yay castle now when I
give chess lessons like I'm doing now
I say develop all your pieces in castle
and fight in the center and then when I
watch you guys play it's like you're
playing some other game okay none of
that stuff happens then when I look at
games between the bet world's greatest
players it happens every game amazing
you would think that's something very
easy to do like I'll get my bishops the
nights out and castle and yet very few
people do it I'd like to thank all of my
opponents very nice of you that's why I
haven't lost a tournament game in six
months because you guys you know you're
moving your king up the board then
you're like Stein it's this come on
alright Bishop to d2 developing his last
piece now with all the minor pieces
developed the players agreed to it now
they didn't do that wreck a CA wreck a
c1 wreck FDA it's like they're playing
great over here now this position is
about equal and everybody's happy white
plays efore this is good and bad it's
good to advance on the center it's bad
to weaken your d4 pawn because sometimes
black wants to play Knight c5 and if
white has a pawn on d4 Black's not going
to play 95 but if those pawns get traded
the black still play 95 so black decided
to take the a pawn
I can't really blame them they took the
a pawn and white played rare k1 and also
took the a pawn Wow and anyone crazy why
is that what did I do to you why is the
computer always doing that stuff to me
I'm innocent
okay so he played djc 5 question mark I
just something I would still go to c5
didn't you hear me instead of taking on
a6 with an equal position a5 saving his
pawn what is the German word we use for
such a move let's call it a random
and Danny days like wait this is harder
than usual it's the German word he
didn't take bad right away
Julian help them out yeah but what's the
German word there you go the the South
American tells us right exactly might
there might be so then I heard it was a
German guy hanging out in South America
you know what I'm saying hey guys I've
got to be careful Ken West you verify
that all right because when I watch The
Simpsons and Family Guy that's that's
what it seems like what's happening okay
so a fun normally you would just take on
c5 then you got you got to worry about
these two pawns
now those pawns are looking good and if
anybody knows what looking good is it's
kind of West esquire all right
sort of like Kevin Durant Esquire very
similar very similar if you've seen
those commercials okay so a5 Bishop e3
defending his pawn tax like 80 times 95
and if I count correctly and I learned
how to count on Sesame Street so other
than the RR odds I'm pretty good at it
9 take c5 Black is a pawn ahead Black
has an extra pawn the queenside what a
terrible play from cara's maybe they
told to lose reshef ski too but why all
right so obviously colored bishops draw
agreed now as I said in my previous
lecture on Tuesday obviously called
vicious means nothing when you only have
bishops and maybe it's a draw maybe not
when there's queens and rooks and Kings
and lions and tigers and Cleveland
Indians and Cleveland Cavaliers Chicago
Bulls then you just win obviously Connor
bishops are good because you can attack
now one thing you don't know because you
know most of my jokes already is this
pawn structure is that better for a dark
squared bishop or a white squared bishop
that you unknown person yeah my dark
square bishop is awesome because the
pawns are on the white squares this
bishop can do anything this bishop
however
that's annoying okay and that's going to
be a week forever so my bishop is better
than your bishop and I have an extra
pawn so you have a lot of issues not
only do you have to defend F to the
whole game you got to make sure I don't
get a queen on the Queen side so you
have two problems here okay you played
b3 obvious move solidifying his Bishop
Bishop to d4 attacking the rook care I
saw it amazing
a4 okay so if you want to make a queen
and the rooks not on the a file that's
probably the way to do it pawn takes b3
man when I'm white I hate when that
happens
okay so the obvious variation if you
play Bishop takes b3 what is white do or
black somebody Martin right what do you
think of that position who's it good for
is it good for white or good for black
very good for black so do I do that now
on the other hand blacks gonna play b2
so it's looking good for black b3 x
clamp yeah I know why I just told him
that okay
now you play g3 and there they give this
crazy variation which is obviously
winning for black every legal move wins
here I assume they give rook takes d1
but I mean okay rook c2 probably doesn't
win yeah they gave rook takes two I knew
they would do that all right check and
take the Queen rook takes Queen and even
most of you could win that position not
not you at home but you know here
okay so white didn't give all his pieces
away
instead he played g3 and as my dad used
to say make lifts not war
okay then he would fight people because
then you make war
all right so g3 no more checkmate b2 now
we'd like to play rook to b1 and block
the pawn but then you might lose your
bishop so that rook like me
is what walking into the worst joke ever
man well your answer is better than mine
as Groucho would say so we will continue
hopefully you at home didn't hear that
and if you if you didn't hear you said
overworked
okay so rook to c2 and now black has
nothing opposite bishops there's no pins
there's no past pawns on the seventh oh
wait a minute that would be overloaded
wait a minute yeah so this is terrible
for white for the following reasons I
just stated this pawns on the seventh
rank this vicious better than your
Bishop factor should be the other way
around because that bishops envious of
this Bishop way green with envy disputes
embarrassed either they're both red
alright
and you know the rook on d1 is stopping
b1 very suspicious for white Bishop
takes F to check Julian would play that
in millionth of a second in a blitz game
right even for lost especially if it
lost okay
now Queen takes f2 isn't good because of
rook takes rook King takes f2 seems even
worse I play Queen b6 check and rook
takes rook and I queen so he played wait
he went back back in time Wow
so he played King g2x clam okay that's
the best move I agree Bishop to d4 and
okay instead of resigning he kept
playing resigning would have been better
very insulting and then look at that
terrible going back in time I mean we
need a new computer and you have a
shopping list a like some shoes and you
come on you know a nice chair here would
be good maybe like a Perrier come on
maybe what he wants period well
obviously okay so this should be one
that's the most active rook takes e4 if
I pun didn't resign here I would get
pretty mad queen d3 rugby for what's
what they're not resigning King age
three
a instead of resigning kh3 Wow all right
well I guess time trouble makes fools of
us all now unfortunately black
accidentally played rook FA an audience
isn't as smart as I thought
hope you're laughing at home and then
queen h7 mate what a great game no black
played rugby shup now queen h7 is not me
fact is my beginners class i was showing
this before take that queen takes most
of you would queen here and then queen
d8 mate black decided not to get mated
white was very insistent and black was
like no and then he's like RI if you
only meet you I'll give up I should have
shown this given my beginner class
because it was back rank mate
yeah and now white resigned about 10
moves too late
very very insulting I like that I also
don't like to resign so that was one
reshef skis best wins black against one
of the greatest players ever Paul Kerr
is right then of course alright and
let's see your tape is running out
alright now my favourite world champion
obviously is next move a from your
favorite country the Netherlands very
good you the camera operator is going to
tell you guys right okay and the let's
you make the judge joke again now we'll
skip over that
okay so reshef ski is white and they're
playing in the world championship
tournament in 1948 julian why did such a
tournament exist why would they have a
tournament and not a match between two
people what's that
now you're talking there was no world
champion so then they're like long why
wasn't there world champion Julian he
died yeah then there's like no world
champion right when the world champion
is alive usually they play a match and
they lose now the reason I was saying
that when Bob Vinick was the world
champion which became in this tournament
he never won a matches world champion he
would either lose then he'd win the
rematch or he would draw okay he's world
champion he didn't want to win because
that would be mean but he had like you
know rematches and you know he had like
you know people with him he had
everything going on so he was world
champion on and off forever
my favorite Bob Phoenix story when he
was world champion they didn't want to
put him on the Olympic team because he
was no good okay well they had Smee slav
and they had tall they had Petrosian
they had Cara's they had Geller like
you're no good God here okay instead
they decided to put him on board wanting
won the gold medal so maybe he was okay
okay so this is a game with chefs key
versus Irv a max is actually really was
not sealed goose but okay too
complicated for this obviously Queen's
Gambit because it's 1940s okay and they
played the semi Slav very suspiciously
Bishop b4 you'll never see that move
again okay and I'm sure everybody in the
class knows the most common move for
black is D takes e4 unless you're Arthur
biz guy then what's the most common move
no now now Bishop d6 yeah but if you're
not on through big R that if D takes e4
okay and one of the things you've been
taught many many times if you do take
this pawn you'd prefer white to move the
bishop then move the bishop again not
take it when the bishop hasn't moved yet
this is a good time to do it this should
be four with all the pawns on white
squares okay
black doesn't want to trade this Bishop
black one season
his bishop so Bishop b4 we're going to
see a lot of Bishop moves by that Bishop
ka3 he's like please trade please trade
now okay and they kept playing and some
reason the bishop was on a5 terrible
okay but nervin was quite a good player
and actually as a theoretician in his
day okay c5 terrible
got the kramnik past pawn fact after the
game in the notes rich st wrote I got
the Kramnik past pawn so he was ahead of
his time okay pass D pawn strong d6 d6
what kind of move is that terrible
okay so d6 is very tricky Julian would
planted a 1-minute game the ideas of
Queen takes d6 I'll play Knight d5 with
discovered attacks and regular attacks
heart attack so he play Queens e8
defending his Bishop rook to d1 and
blacks obviously already lost terrible
rugby a horrible and reshef ski chase
into school picked him up at 3:30 very
nice of him okay and when terrible we
complained earlier luckily for our live
audience my comers not here he'd be like
the bishop on CA RR he'd be so mad okay
he's right too sometimes he's right
happens can you check and see if there's
a blue moon outside Thanks also can you
go to the bar over there give me a blue
moon
all right so II for very suspicious move
the ideas obvious Julie we played at a
one minute game Queen takes e4 Knight f6
with a brilliant fork so 9 g5 and now e4
is hanging Queen h7 Bates coming I'm
going to sack out f7 to one minute game
right and for some reason this Bishop is
still on c8 I guess he likes being on c8
b 5 attacking the bishop bishop saves
itself Queen b6
yum-yum-yum and white is not only up a
pawn but he has a passed pawn on d6
and he has some tricky dating threats
which I don't see this night g5 is
pretty good 9 c5 Knight f6 Knight d7
double X clam I wish I saw that okay so
he played g6 making it very difficult to
do any of that
Queen c3 I got another diagonal for you
alright and blacks doing great as long
as you change the definition of great
then you're good
black threatens mate and white saw it
yeah okay White's up up has D pawn so
that's not good there goes the D pawn
there goes the G pawn and rook takes d7
very suspicious G takes h5 takes takes
takes and now he transforms from the
winning middle game to the winning
endgame f4 and Weiss King goes for a
walk okay and another dire straits Joc
walk of life okay good and unfortunately
for black these pawns keep these pawns
on white squares so White's going to
take those and those pawns can't move so
white one very easily and as was the
custom of the day when they got to time
control black resigned black actually
played Bishop c8 then resigned why you
making weird noises my computer program
earlier indicated after King D for that
white is plus five plus five is good
then you go numb yum-yum-yum-yum
all for free and this King can go
anywhere Bishop can do anything and so
black resigned before King D four was
played so nice keep Irish chefs key or
if it wasn't a bad play it gets a bad
rap because they always have a list of
the weakest world champions how give me
a weak world champion okay maybe he was
so it's funny when I lived in Belgium
before you were born even you can west
Trivial Pursuit was being played the
the Dutch version okay so let's check in
make any of those jokes because the FCC
Logan is um but you don't talk about Ken
West all right you know what jokes I'm
going to make anyway one of the
questions was who is the greatest Dutch
player of all time right and the guys
were playing with chess players so
they're like oh this guy who is will
champion and the answer was young T bond
so there you go yeah
tough game harsh it's tough but fair
right okay
so we'll skip over this game in this
game and this game in this game and that
game and I want to show you this game
this is my favorite chefs T game because
he was losing I'm of nine okay and I
said did you play the opening while he
said nine actually I saw moshevsky once
in Detroit
he gave a simultaneous exhibition and we
were cheating there was a guy playing
and we were talking what to do and then
he won No so remember when if you can
lose if you must but always cheat right
okay so this is a game fishery chefs key
if you own a copy of my 60 memorable
games you'll remember this game
I'm sure you've memorized all sixty nice
fine intelligent audience here and this
game Fisher trick for chef ski in the
opening they played an accelerated
dragon this could be a Mike Hummer
lecture because he likes to have black
in this position Bishop c4 Bishop b3 and
now we're chefs key played 95
grandmasters don't play Knight a5
anymore because of this game
that's why ken west doesn't play it okay
we got about 12 minutes right we're good
yeah we're good what it's in time okay
so notice the knight on c6 defends the
e5 square so most grandmasters would
play queen a5 or d6 some normal move but
reshef ski is like gimme gimme gimme
I want that Bishop that bishops strong
okay and fishers like hey you undefended
the e5 square and the director was
called and said don't talk during the
game yep and he played he five
complicated right yeah
now the Knights attacked work of the
night goes safely very safe the safest
move ever and I couldn't ask if it was
safe because Marathon Man hadn't come
out yet 1958 u98 all right now Fischer
play the most famous move that reshef
skis ever faced I'm sure you all know
it's you can all y'all at the same time
you've all memorized this game from
years ago in your chest training you
what's that you forgot your memorization
you've never seen this game have you
what you haven't you forgot how could
you forget every Russian schoolboy don't
sue me your mo well you could sue me but
don't win alright your Mo's the only
Grand Master has ever strangled me he's
the only one okay probably long whatever
whoo oh no I have a few more years left
it was during a tennis match it's a long
story
you 96 yeah back to the west coast with
you yeah now see now there's the highest
rated player in the room see is he yeah
they saw the game of the one half right
Bishop takes f7 check reshef ski didn't
see that coming okay if he saw it coming
he wouldn't have played Knight a5 now in
my sixth interval games Fisher was like
oh this is Soviet analysis I knew
everything okay and obviously if you
play King h8 that's not the refutation
although it might be the computer move
okay so he took with a king if you take
with a rook which is also legal 96 I
hate when that happens
unless I'm Wyatt now I love it okay and
the queen is trapped
thanks to the night on 85 that funny
night tonight yeah okay so he took with
the king
okay and now this is your chance Kyle
say it again third time claim a draw did
we say Queen f3 before what did we say
we've been saying it the whole time it's
the same move you keep saying there you
go there's your 96 yeah now you're
exactly right like everybody else in the
lecture they're able to sleep it on wake
up okay so now pawn takes Queen loses
the coupon takes Knight loses the Queen
so of course that's what he played and
then Queen takes Queen and the night on
85 is attacked if you resign here that's
very embarrassing so you play on forever
okay now when I lost to Novikov in ten
moves I resigned if I played on some of
30 nobody would know but I resign Austin
ten moves reshef ski played on forever
and ever and ever down a queen so you
lost the most interesting move is King
take c6
okay go for a walk right okay now Queen
d5 check with advantage King to f5 and I
haven't looked at this in a thousand
years what did somebody say Queen four
for sure cuz you repeat okay then yeah
now we're good well g4 looks like it
wins and e6 looks like it wins and f4
looks like it wins and if it's blacks
move I'm guessing whites winning because
the king is here so that's that's just
terrible okay
but I'm sure my turn on an engine it
will announce me it'll say made in like
three four three four three it's got to
be me and three okay and we're chef
skiing well fish already knew the
position Reshevsky must have figured out
after Bishop f7 this is prepared
analysis darn I hate when that happens
walking into your pawns preparation
that's annoying it's especially annoying
in 1958 when nobody had prepper
and one of my favorite Fisher stories I
know the one where you fall asleep I
know a lot of Fisher stories one of my
favorites is he was playing in a
tournament and he game ended
he was analyzing with his opponent who
was a grandmaster and they got to the
end of theory on move like nine no
theory existed and Fisher's like I
analyzed this analyze this and they got
some of 21 ional eyes this so the guy's
like man I'm not going to win
yeah like Fisher head oh the whole game
analyzed before because if you want to
be the best player ever that's what you
got to do right maka valve you hear me
talking all right so instead he took
with a pawn not getting checkmated and
then he played on forever and ever and
ever so I would say that he was being
insulted earlier by Kara's but I guess
if you're going to plan a queen down the
whole game I mean I would do that too
but when somebody else does it they feel
my wrath okay and feeling my wrath
there's only one thing better than that
and what is it drilling in class
dismissed